My brother-in-law who doesn't drink was told that he has
Nash, not an alcoholic, fatty liver disease.
Would your clinic be able to help him with this process?
This doctor said to lose weight, and that's it.
He has had bleeding with his bowel movements for the past five years or so.
But sad doctors just ignore and dismiss.
I watch Nathan Craig's documentary.
The missing leg, cougar, and kids are going to learn about your practice.
So, I'll tell you, non-alcoholic fatty liver disease is super common.
So, I would actually doubt that that is what is the cause of his bleeding.
So, you got to investigate that separately.
Non-alcoholic fatty liver disease is just going to cause dysfunction with the liver.
So, you're going to have a decrease rate of detoxification.
And as that progresses, it's going to affect the liver's ability to go to phase two, phase three, the production of bile.
You could end up with blocked bile ducts.
You could have all sorts of problems with fatty liver disease.
And that's something that is not to be ignored.
Now, how do you treat that? That's another thing.
Helping with the detox pathways.
I would certainly look at this person's genetic detox pathways as well to see what needs to be supported there.
But I don't believe that that's going to be a causative factor of causing bleeding in the stool.
So, with bleeding in the stool, that's a different differential diagnosis pattern you have to go through.
It's very common to have red blood in your stools.
If you have a feature, a broken, what's called a feature in your anal area, which is basically a broken blood vessel.
And you'll get red blood in your stools.
That is extremely common. Everybody's probably had that at any given time.
Usually from having difficult bowel movements straighted at the stool, et cetera.
You can have hemorrhoids causing a bleeding hemorrhoid causing red blood in the stool.
If it's darker stool or you have a consistently dark stool or black stool or a tarry stool,
you have to consider bleeding higher up, and the blood is becoming digested basically.
And then you're getting this black tarry stool.
That's a totally different issue. That's most likely a bleeding ulcer could be stomach ulcer or the blood ulcer.
So, you want to investigate that.
So, for the doctor, if he had told his physician that he had bleeding stools for the last five years,
and the physician didn't recommend a colonoscopy or something like that,
or at hard time believing that could be just ignored.
So, you definitely want to investigate that a little deeper.
Always with bleeding stools, you're concerned about polyps, you're concerned about, you know,
other issues that, of course, as a color of the blood is because that tells you how high it is.
Anal issues, rectal issues, et cetera. You want to investigate that.
It's not something to be ignored.
Now, certainly fatty liver diseases and something to be ignored either.
And just losing weight with that help.
Well, sure it would help because you'd have to clean up your diet to lose weight, typically.
So, as you're cleaning up your diet, you're going to be helping to clean up the liver.
So, this person should have gotten a complete metabolic panel to look at liver markers.
Should look at a CBC markers. This should be the least of all the blood work to do.
A complete CBC with differential, complete metabolic panel with liver markers.
And I would also look at total lipids, a complete liver panel.
So, could we help a person with this? Well, I don't know if we could help a person with this.
But we'd certainly want to do some more investigation to get to down to some root causes and to deal with those root causes.
Just to say that, oh, that alcoholic fatty liver disease is common and you just lose weight is just to be ridiculous
because you're not getting to the cause and not getting to help solve this person's issues.
Why is fatty liver disease, not a alcoholic fatty liver disease, getting to be so common?
That would be another question. And I believe it's because of the amount of toxins in our environment
we're exposed to, we weigh more toxins quantity-wise than our ancestors ever were.
And that puts a lot of stress on our liver pathways.
And when we put that much stress on our liver pathways, we could get laid out of fats and that's an attempt to try to heal that.
And that's where that comes from. So, yes, I would say cleaning up a person's diet would be important.
But digging into some specific toxins and how to support the toxicification of those toxins make more sense.
And that's to be, you know, practice of standard medicine say that they want to get much more specialized and much more unique.
And then they still do stuff like this is kind of like that.
But yeah, they can, and if you are watching this and you have any interest in contacting our clinic,
you could go to cuttersclinic.com. Call our clinic or you could actually schedule a case review.
That's what we call your initial appointment with me. It's a 30 minute online.
Over the phone communication that we have going over your case and see if your case is something that I think we can help you with or you feel comfortable working with us.
So, anybody can do that.
So...